make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking back up again with too
powerful for the mortal Cinematic
Universe what I want to do here is I
want to talk about the white phoenix of
the crown which is kind of like an
expansion of the phoenix force we might
call it like phoenix slash white phoenix
just to kind of make it easier but the
idea behind this is kind of explain this
a little bit because the phoenix is
really really interesting but there's
two aspects to it there there's kind of
two concepts when it comes to the
phoenix there's the phoenix force as you
think of it which is what you'll see in
like the dark phoenix movie and then
there's the white phoenix of the crown
so when it comes to the phoenix force of
mobile comics it's a multiversal entity
and what that means is that across all
the universes that exist in the entirety
of Marvel Comics there's only one
Phoenix force now the Phoenix force may
split itself among various people in
different universes meaning there's an
alternate reality where like Cyclops
becomes the Phoenix there's an alternate
reality where like Magneto becomes the
Phoenix but it doesn't matter at the end
of the day those are all just different
representations of the same Phoenix
force power which only exists in one
form and so what this means is that the
Phoenix is effectively the sum total of
all life that has ever currently does
and will ever exist in the multiverse
now the reason why this matters is
because universes are being formed and
destroyed all the time in the Marvel
multiverse right like that happens all
the time in the same way that in in our
universe here in like the real world
stars are burning out and being born all
the time the exact same thing happens
with the universe with the various
universes and so because universes are
constantly being killed and being reborn
the Phoenix force has a constant source
of power essentially it'll always exist
until the time when the multiverse dies
the Phoenix force will always continue
to exist now conventional wisdom would
say that the Phoenix forces power would
begin to wane as the as the multiverse
approaches this end but that's not the
case because the Phoenix force the
source of its power is not the all life
in the multiverse that will exist it has
ever and currently does and so say that
the multiverse came into existence at
like Year Zero and a year like Tim
trillion it'll come to an end what that
means is that as you get closer to the
Year ten trillion the Phoenix forces
power is still bolstered or or still
maintained by all the years that came
before that mark that you are when
you're closer to ten trillion so if
you're like you're nine trillion then
you the Phoenix force still has like
nine trillion years where the power of
that if that makes any sense but when
the Phoenix force manifested the
earliest story that we have goes back
millions and millions and millions of
years and it was originally
covered in excalibur number 50 and what
you had is you had a guy named net crumb
I think is what it was he was basically
an alternate realities version of like
Doctor Strange the sorcerer supreme and
necron had this idea to essentially take
to have these kind of pillars of
creation brought together and the reason
why is because necron discovered that
the kind of border so to speak around
every universe houses power is basically
the power that those borders use to keep
the universes from crashing into each
other and so what ended up happening is
mech realm realized you could tap into
that power and if you did you could use
that power to your own ends well then he
started asking the question what if I
used all the power from all the borders
of all the universes that exist across
the multiverse with that rationale what
he did is he basically tricked the
Phoenix into creating these kind of
pillars across the multiverse to merge
all the universes into one which would
in turn bolster all the power at the
edge of the universes he would then
absorb that power into himself and
basically become God and do everything
you know anything he wanted to do and so
he was essentially defeated by a handful
of different people and when the Phoenix
force realized what he was trying to do
it basically deactivated and destroyed
all the pillars and set everything back
to the way it was supposed to be and so
from that point going forward the
Phoenix force kind of took off into
space now following that the Phoenix
actually ended up returning to Earth in
Jason Aaron's Avengers 1 million BC
storyline where it basically kind of
manifested in its in its like actual
form and appear to Odin and the two of
them had relationship for a while that's
still being fleshed out so there's
really not a whole lot of information to
go on but following that and following
the debut of Jean Grey and Marvel Comics
following her birth the fact that she
was really really powerful and so on and
so forth she had a young friend named
Annie and Annie was a girl who was
basically killed in a car accident when
she was hit by a car while riding her
bike and when Jean Grae user telepathy
that's happened to the mind of Annie in
her final moments Jean Grey was
overwhelmed by the experience of what it
meant to die and sent out the psychic
signal now the psychic signal had to to
results the first is that Charles Xavier
picked up on it which is why he brought
her to the x-men in the first place but
the second part the second result of
this psychic signal is that the Phoenix
picked up on it and when it did it
basically realized this person is is
almost a perfect host meet Jesus she's
almost perfectly in tune so it would be
like if you and somebody else sung at
the same note right like it like g-sharp
if you sung it the exact same note then
that's basically what this was Jean Grey
was a pretty sure hug for the Phoenix
and so the so the Phoenix sorted
watching Jean and basically saying
somewhere along the line I'm going to
bond with her and when that happens
we will go forward as a singular entity
and that's what happened during the
Phoenix saga and so that that leads up
to that whole set of events now of
course that goes into a whole other
series of issues you know Dark Phoenix
and so on and so forth which probably
deserve videos on their own when the
Dark Phoenix movie drops but what you
have there is you you have the Phoenix
force which bonded to Jean and basically
at a future point in time Jean became
the white Phoenix of the crown now what
does that mean okay technically speaking
the Phoenix force can bond itself to
anybody
apocalypse the villain could become the
Phoenix Iron Man Tony Stark could be
could be a host for the Phoenix force
but just because you're a host for the
Phoenix force does not mean that you can
use the full extent of its power the
white phoenix of the crown which is to
say a person who is a perfect host of
the Phoenix can use the full totality of
the Phoenix's powers now how does a
person become a perfect host of the
Phoenix that's never explained only two
people have ever done it Hope Summers
and Jean Grey and that's it those are
the only two people who have ever become
a perfect hosts of the Phoenix and
Marvel just says it's because they're
just a perfect host and that's really
all it is now what does it mean when a
person becomes the white Phoenix of the
crowds well it means they can do
anything they want to and that was
covered in Grant Morrison's here comes
tomorrow storylines when he kind of
talks about the idea of the white
Phoenix and says that the white Phoenix
exists a quote-unquote fix things that
are wrong in universes what does that
mean it means the white Phoenix is
essentially a multiversal reality warper
that can bend and reshape the multiverse
in whatever way it wants to but the
difference here is that at the end of
the day it's still a person and that's
the cool thing and that's that's kind of
our way about saying too powerful for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but how
they could also be defeated so say for
example in the MCU the Captain America
because of the fact that he's so
patriotic and does the right thing that
he is a perfect host for the Phoenix and
Captain America becomes the white
Phoenix to the crown so basically his
suit turns like completely white the
decidua on his chest turns to like gold
and silver and basically like he just
kind of goes forward with like
multiversal reality warping power at the
end of the day he is still a person the
white phoenix of the crown doesn't
really transcend the mind of the person
whose power inherits it it's just a
sudden influx of power and basically
like they're hugely capable in what they
can do Captain America would be mentally
unstable he really I mean while he is a
perfect host the mind being able to
grasp cosmic awareness which is to say
knowing everything that's going on
across the multiverse in that instance
at that point in time would be [ __ ]
would be almost completely overwhelming
and so if he didn't end up in a comatose
state he would basically start to break
down and begin to lose his mind that
would make him mentally unstable in his
mental instability who you wouldn't be
able to mentally grasp in his totality
all the power he possesses at his
disposal which means he wouldn't be able
to tap in all that power immediately now
again that's the difference if someone
like Iron Man is not fully compatible
with the Phoenix even if when is even
when his mind becomes right and even
when he regains his sanity he wouldn't
be able to tap into the Phoenix's full
powers when Captain America's mind
restabilized and he goes back to being
sane he would be able to use the full
power of the Phoenix force now in that
window however long that window happens
to be whether it's a day whether it's a
couple years Captain America would still
be exceedingly dangerous but he can
still be defeated because if he's not
able to tap into the full total of the
full power of the Phoenix that means he
can't do things like make himself
bulletproof it means he can't do things
like keep himself from being you know
harmed in any capacity from like
changing bullets in a gun to like
snowflakes for those of you guys who
remember the Watchmen there's a lot of
things he can't do and so he's not
immutable indestructible and unbeatable
yet and that's the window the Avengers
have won they would have to understand
what's going on with him and then to
realize or come to the conclusion that
there's no saving him that he has to be
destroyed in order to save the universe
and then kill him at that point it's
quick fast and in a hurry there's
there's not much going on there he could
be destroyed right off the bat and super
easily but let's say for example that
Captain America's mind we stabilizes key
regains the full total power or he gains
at the I guess total access to the full
power of the Phoenix force and then
decides to attack and destroy the
universe no one would be able to stop
them there's nothing you could do to
stop him because he's a multiversal
entity there's some total power of
everything that's there wouldn't be able
to defeat him now the only question that
comes into play is something like what
would happen if somebody had the
Infinity stones to my knowledge up to
this point in Marvel Comics we've never
seen a story where the Infinity stones
had faced off against the Phoenix force
we probably will somewhere along line
because it's a clickbait story I'd read
the heck out of it
all dude if I do if I did a video did
they'd like told the story of somebody
with the Infinity Gauntlet fighting
somebody with like the full power of the
Phoenix force all that video would blow
up oh my god it would go nuts you guys
would watch the hell out of that video
you guys are just got to see this man
like I got to see this like Daniels with
the Infinity Gauntlet versus the white
phoenix of the crown all people would
watch the heck out of that but still
like as far as I'm aware it doesn't
exist so we don't really have an answer
to that question we could we could power
scale but at that point where does kind
of cook in the books to make whatever
argument we want to make and so again
this is it
you're seeing there but kind of going
with what we've seen in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe up to this point
anybody who's like a white feed a to the
crown there's nothing that could stop
them because it'd be like if the Living
Tribunal showed up and said I want to
destroy your universe well there's not
gonna be able to do anything then
there's nothing they can do to stop and
because of how her so extreme but again
in that small little moment there
Captain America or whoever's the white
Phoenix could easily be destroyed if
they haven't quite gained an
understanding of the kind of power they
possess and they're mentally unstable
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]